I was in steel training on 9 11. the
instructors they said gentlemen we're
going to war and we're gonna beat you
until those of you who don't want to be
here quit steel training is really about
like one thing it's about figuring out
who's gonna ring that Bell you did a
piece with Vice you're like uh another
shooting at a Pokemon there's like a guy
hanging out on the side with like a
machine gun he's like you can just tell
like you're much more comfortable than I
think like a normal journalist would be
if we are not just giving veterans A
Renewed sense of mission and purpose but
we're not also paying attention to their
Financial Security all of the mission
stuff in the world isn't gonna matter
all right guys bang bang I've got kazir
with me uh I thought a great place to
start Navy SEAL training uh is one of
the toughest military schools that
someone can go through uh it's brutal I
think over the last couple of years more
and more seals have started to talk
about their experiences people have seen
folks like David Goggins or Jocko
willnick and somebody's individual tools
become very popular in the civilian
world but there's a lot of change going
on how do you think about your
experience training and the things that
you went through would that be cool
today would they would they still do
those same things or has it changed well
it it's interesting it's funny you just
brought up a couple of my friends you
know the seal Community is tightness
Community Jocko was my first Jiu Jitsu
instructor and the one of the best
things about Jocko is like there's no
Persona there's no artifice there like
with Jocko it's like that old school
computer language wishy-wig what you see
is what you get that is Jocko like
unadulterated
um and I was I was sort of reared
literally he was my first Jiu Jitsu
coach he was slightly he's a slightly
senior officer to me in the Seal team so
I was a very junior junior officer and
he was a junior officer at the same time
so we're of that same generation
um and you know like I like to think I'm
you know slightly more refined you know
Jocko could be pretty Paleolithic at
times uh but yeah
increasingly like I was in Seal training
buds basically underwater demolition
SEAL training on 9 11. on yeah I was in
first phase of buds I just completed a
two mile ocean swim and I remember that
day very distinctly because prior to
that you could kind of call the SEAL
Teams maybe like a shoot dive jump club
right it was a good time right and
people you know I didn't know much about
seals when when I went in we weren't
high profile in the media the way we are
today uh but like you know pejoratively
you could say like oh those guys they're
just like this like small unit like
doing their thing it wasn't as
operational obviously September 11th
changed all of that for both the seal
community and for myself so you're in
the water 911 happens and you get out
and there's like hey guys somebody's
flew a plane into the tower like how do
they tell you yeah we were we were
changing out in you know you're doing
this like quick where you get rid of
your rubber fins and you're taking off
your wetsuit and stripping down and
you're always rushed and then uh those
those two mile ocean swims in the
morning right after that you run to the
chow hall so they you start at like 5
a.m or something and by the time you
finish you're running over trying to
make it to the chow hall with your class
before they close it's another mile and
a half run to get over to the chow hall
uh and as we were changing out you could
sort of hear whisper rumors there's all
these sort of besides the instructors
peripheral Personnel who are like you
know helping maintain medical personnel
and stuff like that somebody was saying
oh a plane hit the World Trade Center
and all this stuff so as we were running
over to the chow hall that rumor was
kind of circulating through at this
point the class is still very large you
know 200 plus guys right my class
started with 246 guys we graduated 26
Originals so we were still this big
massive raging horde at this point
running over to the chow hall on the
other side of the amphibious space and
uh people were sort of saying like a
plane hit the tower I candidly thought
that it might have been a ruse of the
instructors because they're always doing
things that [ __ ] with you right and
they're always playing these little [ __ ]
[ __ ] games and so I was like oh this is
another one of their games and then we
got over to the chow hall and there was
TVs in the chow hall because that's
where the regular Naval Personnel eat as
well so there was T it's not as austere
people who didn't go on the two mile
swim right a mile and a half run to get
there yeah they're just waking up
getting their coffee you know yeah we
call it the shoe Navy right uh as
opposed to the boot Navy uh so then on
the TV screens
um we saw the images right and then I
knew that this was real partially
because like the instructors frankly
aren't that sophisticated they could
never pull off this right so we come
back from the chow hall it's very
obvious that something catastrophic has
happened and the instructors
to their credit they had an incredibly
Clairvoyant clear sense of what was
going on and they said gentlemen we're
going to war and we're going to beat you
until those of you who don't want to be
here quit and that's what they did and
that was a horrific day for us just a
physically grueling day
um and you know for us you're a bud
student there's like lots going on it's
hard to think through the Strategic
implications of what had happened but
for these guys the instructors who their
buds assignment is just a rotation just
come from an operational Seal Team they
knew really quickly what it meant and so
they had an even more clarified sense of
mission and purpose that day because
they knew that guys us the guys in the
class the students like we were gonna
rotate if we graduated we were going to
be in platoons fighting right alongside
those instructors so uh yeah they beat
the hell out of us a bunch of people
quit and uh and that's that was my
entrance to the teams did they change
the training at all in terms of trying
to accelerate folks or was this a point
where uh a lot of the units still had
enough people where if they were sent
out then hey we're good we don't need to
actually change training accelerate the
graduation of people or anything like
that one of the things that's
interesting about the seal selection as
you mentioned is generally considered
you know some of the hardest military
Special Operations selection in the
world is no matter how big they open the
funnel at the top they really pretty
much seem to get the same number
exactly like it's remarkable how
unchanged and how similar it's been
through since the creation of the the
Seal team since President Kennedy
created the SEAL Teams back in 1961.
yeah it's crazy to me also I think um
how celebratized uh the seal teams have
gotten and uh the few that I know they
are like hey I that's like a weird thing
that's not how this was supposed to to
happen but it makes sense that uh
whether it's Hollywood the media whoever
like what better story than like oh
these guys are swimming you know uh in
the dark of night and showing up with
guns and like like it's a story that
they want to tell but it is very uh in
contrast I think to a lot of the ethos
of the unit right yeah I mean this is a
little bit seal inside baseball but you
know when I end entered the SEAL Teams
you know I was I was playing water polo
at the Naval Academy I look back at my
water pole team from the Naval Academy
and something like of the 21 of us like
14 of us went Naval special Warfare
which is the Seal team so it was a
feeder a pipeline program that prior to
that I had never really even heard of
Navy SEALs yeah like I every back back
when I back in the old days right it was
all Chuck Norris Delta Force everybody
was talking about Delta Force Delta
Force right now delft of force was like
sort of like you know smirking at us
like oh we're the real quiet
professionals now and you guys are these
like you know Hollywood hair gel guys
right
um I think like many corporate
institutions there was this inflection
point in 2011 right where we went from
having an ethos of what we called the
quiet professional and then we had to
transition to this very public-facing
role right the idea that we were going
to continue to remain the quiet
professionals
um and out of the spotlight after or Bin
Laden arguably the single most important
Mission operation since World War II
um to me that was untenable right like
we were very firmly in the public
Spotlight and like any organization
we've had sort of some real growing
pains with going from a shadowed
organization into one that's directly in
the spotlight and I think we're still
going through that today when you see
the bin Laden uh raid and and the
killing of Bin Laden how much of the
Public's interest like obviously it's
Bin Laden right so there's a lot of
people who cared about it uh but the
story of how it happened the helicopter
goes down and kind of all these things
that really I think put a light onto oh
these are these professionals who are
prepared for any situation and uh most
people if they were just sent to do
something like this and the helicopter
went down they'd like call their boss
and be like hey what do we do right uh
but the seals got the job done and we're
able to get themselves out and was
killed uh from the American side like
all these things how much of the story
shined a light on it on top of it being
Bin Laden himself I think what it
exposed and look all the better dude to
talk about this is my friend Rob O'Neill
I'll introduce you guys you guys are
going to love each other great dude
um and you know Rob talks about this
extensively you know from an operational
perspective I I think part of the reason
that besides just like you implied that
it wasn't just that it was Bin Laden
right it was that pulling this off in
Pakistan which is arguably one of the
most dangerous countries in the world
right it's a nuclear armed Nation
um that we've had a very complex
relationship with throughout the
conflict in Afghanistan pulling that off
despite all of the obstacles right
um is is impressive right it was that's
textbook like we had spent a decade
sharpening the knife preparing for that
kind of operation but it all goes back
to what happens in Seal training in buds
right the ethos is you're taught to
improvise to adapt to overcome and to
accomplish the mission like regardless
of what obstacles are thrown in your
face SEAL training is really about like
one thing it's about who's gonna it's
about figuring out who's gonna ring that
Bell right we say everybody wants to be
a frog man on a sunny day right like
yeah who wants to be a frog man when
you're cold you're wet you're tired
um you're hurting right that's what buds
is it's like there's all these like
tricks and tips and like there's been
some some high profile media articles as
of late about what's happening
um in Seal training uh but you can
really boil it down to its Essence is
somebody gonna ring that Bell or not
yeah again
I've never gone through Navy SEAL
training uh I went through basic
training on the Army side and in some of
those schools uh and they're tough but
as a 17 18 year old kid you know if
you're half athletic and like not an
idiot and don't quit like you'll be fine
um but when I read the articles about
the Seal training on one side I'm like
okay they write it in such a way where
it's like are we killing the seals right
you know like they write it as if it's
literally the the worst thing in the
world on the other side it's like hey
these are the people that we're gonna
send to go fight our enemies on the
battlefield like I want pretty tough
people right want them skilled we want
them to have some of this training how
do you think through the critiques but
also having gone through the experience
of like well maybe some of this is like
by Design or actually is helpful in
sharpening the tools that the nation
uses in war yeah look I I I think you
encapsulated the dichotomy perfectly
there right that
as of late there's been a lot of
attention in Spotlight there was just a
high profile New York Times article that
came out sort of critiquing SEAL
training
um and when I read it I thought to
myself wow this is a real piece of [ __ ]
right and like I actually hold the New
York Times in incredibly High esteem
like I come from the journalism world
right I spend a tremendous amount of
time in my civilian career as a conflict
Zone correspondent right the New York
Times has always been sort of the gold
standard for for journalism in a lot of
ways
um and and I read this front page
article about Seal training and drug use
and culture of drug abuse and I was like
oh this is written by somebody who
fundamentally doesn't understand what's
happening inside the wall and and the
the root of that critique was there was
a death and Seal training about six
months ago the article just came out a
month ago but there was a death and Seal
training a guy
I feel bad butchering his name I think
it's Kyle Mullen uh was his name he
played football at Yale came over to
buds uh went through training and died
post hell week right
um and I think key pieces he made it
through hell week and then like a couple
days after yeah so you you secure hell
week on like a Friday he was in the
barracks that night and uh he I think it
was safe it's sort of unclear like the
you know but essentially like he died as
a result of injuries sustained in hell
week right super tragic uh and I feel
for his family tremendously like him his
mom's been on a big crusade to hold
people accountable and I think that that
is understandable uh and just right and
I think certainly that there was
mistakes made there's a med check
process right I remember when I finished
hell week you know you basically spend
two days in bed recovering peeing in
Gatorade bottles because you can't get
up to go to the bathroom
um but there's supposed to be people who
are coming around and sort of checking
and doing Wellness checks on you and I
think some part of that processing
system failed in the six months since
that has happened I have been able to to
talk to the naval special Warfare Center
and I've been able to observe that they
have fixed though they've plugged those
holes right and so total mistake total
tragic but the indictment of the overall
training process troubles me and the
reason it does is
um because when you look at it in in
aggregate in grand total uh
there's been 11 deaths throughout the
course of the seal history in training
right really and 11 is a tragic number
right but 11 over since
1961 right over the course of you know
50 60 plus odd years almost 70 years of
training uh is not a staggering number
to me you know a little over one a
decade right
um and this is with how many approximate
uh classes are going through buds a year
well this is these are gross
approximations sometimes there's four
classes sometimes there's five classes
right but say a thousand people in here
exactly say a thousand people a year
going through training so
um and like look no death no death no
loss is desired or even acceptable and
and buds is actually a pretty safe
environment right and they do
considering the intensity and the risk
of the training I actually think they do
and I am not like an apology for the
seal Community I would be the first to
sort of you know critique where we can
do better and like that med check
failure is certainly a place that could
be done better but when I really scale
back and look at the 50 000 foot View
it comes down to this for me you're
asking these men and tall men in Seal
training to do super human tasks and
it's very difficult then to hold them to
human standards yeah if you're trying to
do that right we want them to perform
impossible missions and in order to do
that we have to test their metal and we
have to test their metal in the most
extreme close to combat circumstances we
can and that's the best we can do at
Buds and the challenge for the
instructors and for the seal communities
to walk that right up to the line to
simulate as close as we can the
experience of of being in combat and the
rigors and stress of combat uh while
obviously trying to keep people safe and
uh it's sad but to me understandable
that uh in this in this one domain that
occasionally there are accidents
occasionally there are mistakes
um and I I do think that there are
places in the U.S military in our
National Defense where we need those
units we need units that are capable of
doing the hardest dare I say close to
Impossible missions
um and in order to to as you said keep
the knife that sharp you really you have
to push the envelope in training I think
you see this in other communities too
look at uh test pilot school at Edwards
Air Force Base right every one of those
wives if you go back and read like great
books like the right stuff written by
Tom Wolf about the early days of test
pilot school I was just actually out at
Edwards talking to a test pilot family
and they live with this every day they
know those guys are out there in
punching holes in the sky on the edge of
the envelope in order to figure out like
you know what's possible keep the US
military as the tip of the spear
um so I I think overall considering how
extraordinarily dangerous uh SEAL
training is they actually do a decent
job it's not fair I think it's 100 fair
and again from an outsider's view but
understanding of the military what I
always try to do is try to draw a line
maybe from okay so this training that is
very intense I mean we're literally
talking about uh there are people who
are passing out in the water being
revived going right back in the water
like that's not normal right uh it's
kind of like Elon Musk is like I'm
trying to go to Mars did you think I'd
be normal yeah right like I'm trying to
do some of his wild stuff do you think
but if you draw a line to uh Marcus
luttrell's story right and kind of that
mission and I think it's been uh um you
know really blasted out into the media
with the movie and all the stuff it's
like hold on a second we're going to ask
the people who are in that training to
go and be one of the four guys who are
going to fight on this mountain and one
of the four is literally going to be
crawling on his hands and knees with a
broken back and like you go through it
you're like hey maybe we actually owe
these people the the the
ability to be prepared in these
situations right like to some degree
yeah what's the narrative yeah it's like
are we really going to ask these
individuals to go and not give them our
best training yeah nailed it 100 on the
head and you know life is a strangely
full circle Marcus is identical twin
brother Morgan was my swim buddy that
morning on September 11th
so really
um you know our community's small so
it's you know not surprising uh but you
know what I'll say one more thing to to
bash on that that shitty New York Times
article right and why they fundamentally
misunderstand the culture that you and I
come from is the the and maybe this is
more common on the media than than the
article in particular but I looked at
that that headline and it said you know
I've culture of cheating and drug abuse
within SEAL training right uh and they
cited like the the presence of steroids
in uh like you know maybe you know some
of the people who've had medical issues
and stuff it's because they're using
steroids and that they got some
Anonymous quotes or some quotes about
people using you know steroids and in
Seal training and whatnot
um like look I'm here to tell you like
you know like a natural bodybuilder I
didn't use steroids in Seal trading I
performed quite well uh like only an
outsider would make that mistake of
thinking that steroids are an advantage
in Seal training because I think from
the outside you think that these are
physical evolutions and they're not
right the whole purpose of SEAL training
to see if you'll ring that Bell is to
test your grit your mental fortitude
your mental toughness it's a mental
Evolution right and steroids aren't
going to help you they might May maybe
if you had Lance Armstrong's you know
doping guy give you some small
performance Advantage but in general
like it's not physical it's mental and
that's the fundamental mistake we
haven't found the drug that makes you
mentally tough yet right exactly and
that's why I like that that article was
laughable and so when I read a headline
about you know
um about you know culture of drug abuse
so I was like oh no no you fundamentally
don't get it you know headlines like
that and I find this to be a problem
sort of writ large in the media
landscape these days is that the
institution and it's not their fault
they are incentivized for salaciousness
and not for truth yeah yeah I I forget
the exact numbers but one of the most
interesting stats to me I think it's
across all Special Operations the
average uh height and weight it's like
511 180 or 190 right and I think people
because of the media uh and movies and
things like that they think everyone's
six four 250 pounds and I'll rip your
head off yeah like yes they can kill you
but it is uh to some degree uh you need
people who are mentally tough and you
need people who are versatile it's not
just about who's got the biggest muscles
as much as it is who can solve problems
who can do some of these different
things and I think that that gets lost a
lot because sounds great like oh Navy
Seals are all using steroids and you
know of course they are
totally right and not that there aren't
steroids of course there are but when
we're trying to to paint an accurate
picture of an overall Community the
average age of a soft Special Operations
forces operator is 34 years old with two
children right it takes a decade to
develop the skills of jumping diving
shooting in order to conduct missions
like Neptune Spear or Red Wings or any
of these like high profile missions that
you read about or more importantly the
ones you don't read about yeah when uh
when you think of all of the missions
that uh folks are aware of is there one
that you look at in your life that was
some crazy [ __ ] like whenever you talk
to somebody who's trained for something
who's kind of in a club whether it's in
business whether it's in the military uh
Sports whatever most of the things I
think Outsiders are impressed by people
like ah it's cool but like the Insiders
aren't impressed but was there one where
you guys were all like yo that was
[ __ ] cool like like I can't believe
they pulled that off yeah this episode
is brought to you by eight sleep good
sleep is a game changer and the eight
sleep pod is the best sleep machine I
sleep on it every single night a great
night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
and eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eatsleep.com pump not only do
I sleep on it every night it literally
changed my life and I begged the
founders to let me invest in the company
hsleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep well there's a hundred that I can
talk about in 100 that I can't
but I'll tell you something that that
stands out in my mind that's in the
public domain is one that was sort of
portrayed as a failure but I think if we
we look at it from a different
perspective different lens like imagine
what happened so there was an operation
that went down to capture a high profile
a high value Target in Somalia so this
was a terrorist leader if my memory
serves me correct associated with
al-shabab which is one of the terrorist
organizations that operates out of
Somalia it was on a beach north of
Mogadishu he was in a safe house
the the seal operational unit inserted
via water which is our Maritime domain
specialty inserted via water
um in the early hours of the morning
pre-dawn and got in a huge fire fight
with the guards there you know thousands
and thousands of rounds of ammunition
dumped in both directions the
[Music]
the GFC The Ground Force Commander made
the decision to tactically withdraw back
to the water
like any firefight it's messy right it's
a few magazines a few radios get dropped
in you know in in the middle of this
several you guys litter Navy Seals
litter a thousand thousand bucks a
thousand bucks
oh my
God I literally try and sanitize the
beach but you know and so you know there
was like
uh shabab or the the Somali offshoot
group you know they posted some pictures
like oh these guys you know we got in
this big fire fight and we here's the
evidence here's their radio and here's
you know the magazines that that got
left behind or whatever and you know I
guess sort of in terms of mission
objective the the mission was a failure
right they failed to capture that high
value Target right so those are them the
facts right that's what happened right
like they didn't complete the mission
objective right but nobody nobody was
killed right and if you think about what
really happened uh I spent a lot of time
in Somalia Mogadishu
um somalis in general are actually
pretty fearful of the water they don't
swim very well right there's some
fishermen and stuff who are comfortable
but even like some of the Somali pirates
that we rolled up like didn't know how
to swim so here you have like a senior
terrorist leader at his beach house in
Somalia right and in the middle of the
night you know a seal Commando unit
scuba's in inserts from the ocean the
dark ocean shoots up your entire house
kills you know kills so many of your
security guards there's an hour-long
fire fight raging and then poof they
Retreat back into the water in the
middle of the night what's the
psychological effect of that operation
like yes on its face Mission failure
right this guy knows that we can reach
out and touch him sort of anywhere so I
know that's real interesting they
probably don't stay at your beach house
that much exactly right right and so
those are those are the kind of things
that are happening on a consistent basis
and and I think it really uh it really
speaks to the proficiency and the
capability of of the force yeah it it
um it's so much because it's a craft
right like this whole idea of you know
shoot move communicate but also uh when
you add in the water when you add in
jumping and and all these things
um I don't think people actually
understand how many hours go into it as
well like uh uh there's a um I think it
was a TV show uh called the unit I don't
know if you ever saw this yeah and in
one of the scenes uh somebody sent it to
me and and the guy I guess he was having
trouble during training and shooting and
so he went out on a weekend and he's at
the ring he's just shooting and he's
shooting he's shooting shooting and he
shoots so much that he's like tearing up
his hand so he basically just wraps a
cloth around he's still shooting he's
still shooting still shooting and other
than being like is this like what the
military is like I'm like well hold on
there's a very big difference between
like Special Operations regular military
but like that is something that I think
people they associate with sports like
oh you hear a story of Kobe Bryant in
the gym at four o'clock in the morning
or whatever
but to be able to do what you just
described and insert into the water swim
for Miles go up onto a beach get in a
fire fight and then disappear
that's not luck that's not hey we just
woke up this morning and decided we were
going to be good at this it's not the
first time you tried that out
yeah you had some reps yeah and and the
Reps probably were in situations where
if you messed up you didn't get killed
right right like I think that's the
other pieces back to the training piece
right yeah right yeah you don't simulate
that in the pool right when you think of
the training uh you went on after the
seals to do a lot of stuff uh in the
I'll call it the media just overarching
but uh there's special investigations
there's a lot of War correspondent work
um you did a couple of different
organizations talk a little bit as to
like we're just addicted to it like hey
send me to the craziest places uh was it
like let's look around the room who okay
like you have the highest probability of
coming back so you're going whether you
like it or not like how do those
conversations happen when you first get
started yeah well you know I
accidentally fell into the media in my
in my post-seal career
um and interestingly enough this is in
my post active duty career but I was
able to continue to stay in the reserves
and continue to serve while I was doing
War corresponding and while I was doing
my my work in media I like to say like I
was a seal in the media before it was
cool to be a seal of the media right I'm
sure all of your friends love that yeah
yeah
yeah exactly so you know you're welcome
Goggins and Jocko for me Paving the way
for this opportunity uh no it um so when
I transitioned off active duty I
actually ended up going to graduate
school and studying public policy and
and IR
um and when I was in graduate school you
know we were discussing like all of
these issues in this like the lofty
Tower the lofty Ivory Tower of Academia
right um but it was it was sort of
abstract right it was very sort of
classroom oriented even though my
professors were extraordinary had like
lots of Real World Experience there was
this sort of insular bubble nature to
the kind of conversations and I had been
a real world practitioner of it
um downrange and I really thought
it was important from a mission
perspective to be able to show people
some of the experiences that I had
downrange and so that was the Catalyst
for media for me they didn't get it they
uh they didn't want to understand what
was happening what was your experience
when you were talking to these into how
receptive were they to some of your
experiences so this great professor in
grad school who told this this story uh
about a National Conference of
journalists and he's this isn't this is
a guy who wrote The Definitive history
of the New York Times an esteemed
Harvard Professor he actually ran the
shorenstein center at Harvard which is
for press politics and public policy uh
and he told this story that he goes to
this National journalism conference
every year and every year since you know
1955 I was you know he was pretty pretty
geriatric at the point that he was my
professional but really sharp like
sharpest attack and you know he was he
was long in in the tooth and and he said
when they first started this convention
they always start by parading the flag
and the the service Flags down the
middle of of the aisle and they ask
anybody who had served to please stand
up and in the 50s uh you know to pay
respects and and to honor the flag right
the service flags as they came down Army
Navy Marine Corps
um and you know in 19 in the 50s and the
60s when he went to these conventions
and this happened basically every single
journalist in the room stood up because
they had all served in World War II
because the entire nation had been
mobilized and he watched like through
Vietnam and through and then he said you
know in in 2005 the the year that I
entered Harvard uh he told me that that
year he had gone to the convention that
he had asked every journalist in the
room uh who had served in the military
to stand up and nobody stood up so you
had this giant disconnect between
um people who sort of understood War at
a visceral level and the people who were
telling the American public about War uh
and so for me lifetime
Lifetime right in one lifetime he
watched The Evolution and uh and I think
that was true it's it's less true now
you have more and more veterans like
ourselves right you have this great
podcast like you have more of us who are
sort of talking about our experiences
and helping shape the national narrative
and understanding about conflict and and
issues of the day
um but in in 2005 uh you know when I got
off active duty before I transitioned to
the reserves it just wasn't the case
yeah there really weren't a lot of
veterans working in the institution of
media and you know this is a a it's a
bigger problem than just in Media or
it's a bigger issue than just media
there was a book that was written that
year called AWOL uh American Elites
unexcused absence from the military wow
and he talked about you know the
graduating class of 1942 at Harvard
um 100 of eligible males went and joined
the military yeah because it was World
War II middle of World War II and then
he you know fast forward to the year he
wrote the book I can't remember 2004
2003 we were actually still in the
middle of War right two Wars Iraq
nfghanistan uh but like not a single
member of the graduating class of
Harvard that year had entered the
reverse is actually fascinating as well
the camera if it's uh maybe in the 60s
70s I remember to get the the time frame
uh incorrect but uh at one point I think
it was the Fortune 500 87 percent of the
CEOs were military veterans yes and when
they went and looked now it's not zero
but it was significantly less it was
like 10 or something and uh the paper
that I read was basically making the r
argument like don't be surprised they
weren't predicting it as much as just
like uh because we have sent so many for
20 years in Iraq and Afghanistan you're
going to then see these military
veterans rise up in these organizations
the difference was 100 right was going
in in the in the 40s uh and now it's
like one percent of the American
population is engaged and and so you
know there's pluses and minuses to it in
some ways uh wow how amazing is it that
only one percent of our population has
to go and fight and everyone else can
enjoy you know the greatest of America
uh but at the same time like it is
fascinating how different it is now it
it is it is a fundamental sea change um
and look I'm I'm not a veteranophile
right I don't think that like just
because you served in the military you
are going to be an extraordinary CEO
um or an extraordinary journalist or
anything right we know that you and I
know all too well how non-homogenous the
military population and the veteran
population is uh but I do think that
there is something to be said for that
sort of Cadre experience of experience I
do think that there's something to be
said
um for you know what is what is this you
probably know this better like you know
what is being a veteran it's like right
writing a blank check for up into the
value of your life to the United States
government right like uh there is
something that is important in the
National discourse and in the National
leadership of having worn the cloth of
the country and I think we as the
veteran Community do add value
especially now in these like turbulent
times that were like highly partisan
times that we're living in and stuff I
think actually sort of the value of
Uniform service is is even elevated
right now yeah it is um very much uh if
you go back to the early 2000s right uh
what's the easiest way to get rid of all
the partisanship it's like there's some
external threat and if you go back and
and uh people have seen the clip but I
think it's uh George Bush is running out
to do the first pitch of the New York
Yankees game I don't care if you're a
white black brown green purple if you're
a republican Democrat or you're you know
some [ __ ] weird thing that no one
actually knows about you were an
American on that day and
that sounds idealistic but that was only
20 years ago right right like like that
was not uh uh that long ago and
um you know there's people now who if
you think about it are like 18 to 22
that like literally weren't born yet
like I recently uh uh we were working
with somebody and uh we needed date of
birth or something and he told me that
it was 2002 and I like I was like oh
[ __ ] I gotta take a lap
right because like you just forget but
like uh so yes some portion of people on
social media and stuff like this like
literally just don't remember that stuff
um but I do think that it is possible
and obviously we'd like to have more uh
uh uh kind of cohesion without having to
have the external threat but that's just
how Nature has always worked right is
the external threat actually brings
people together yeah I think about you
know at a micro level I always think
about combat
um
this is going to be platitudinal in some
ways but
I combat you know is this thing that for
me it's always had this like clarifying
effect right it's not like you go to
combat and like you go to war and then
you have some Grand Epiphany like oh
life is so sweet I'm gonna enjoy every
moment I'm never gonna argue I'm a Hindu
cow I'm a Zen Buddhist monk now coming
back for more like it's certainly not
like that and obviously with like the
trauma that some people experience it's
tremendously not like that um but for me
like Wars never had this like Grand
Epiphany effect what it's had this
effect of is like racking an aperture
like bringing things into sharper Focus
so when I'm home and I I get to like you
know take a surfer swim in the ocean
right like you know or when I have like
a good meal like things are like
slightly incrementally sweeter they're
like they taste better they feel better
because I've had this this clarifying
fact effect and you know I hope that
that
idea is scalable right that you know
whatever conflict is happening out there
in the world for our our nation like it
does bring some clarity and focus to
like our our national discourse and our
national culture of like the things that
matter like the the things that you know
the truth is like even in this highly
partisan times and we've been through
these eras in history before
um we have much more in common than we
are different yeah and the military
helps teach that which is part of the
value of Uniform service yeah it also um
I always say that uh it's a reminder
daily like in some weird morbid way that
like hey unfortunately nobody gets out
alive and so like enjoy it right to some
degree is like basically what you're
saying totally and uh I think that
people who don't have that experience
they're like oh these guys are [ __ ]
weirdos right whatever but there is this
element of uh uh yes there is the uh
portion of the military who does have
the traumatic experiences but there's
also a portion of the military who
they're much happier people they enjoy
things they let things go that maybe
otherwise they wouldn't if if they
hadn't had the experience and so it's
like very fascinating uh difference of
response and a lot of it has to do with
the experience that they have in the
military
totally totally it I mean it is like
look this is this idea is anathema to
really say at a big level but I know
Stan mcchrystal's a big supporter of it
um I I have always been a supporter of
national service to some degree right
even as like a Unity principle and a
unifying Factor look like like everyone
goes in the military or could it be no
they think anything that could be
national service right in you know with
one stroke of the pen in you know 1962
President Kennedy created both the SEAL
Teams and the Peace Corps which are
these two disparate elements of National
Power right yeah I always like thought
like oh you know in my 60s I'll like
joined the Peace Corps that I'll have
like completed yeah right
the uh uh so you know in some way they
both are intended to keep the piece just
they take different tax that's right and
in some ways and there are parts of the
world where the only Americans that
people might know are either soldiers or
Peace Corps volunteers right so so
that's that's how they how extremely
important that kind of ambassadorship is
but yeah look I think it would basically
look like no you can go into any of
these uniform services it would look
much like the military if you want to go
right out of high schools because some
people are not prepared for a college
right you know this would be your sort
of Gap service year you could go into
the Peace Corps you could go into Teach
for America right you could go into the
military and you would be like enlisted
Cadre in that organization right or if
you went to college and deferred your
national service until post College then
you would be as part of this kind of
like Junior officer leadership Cadre so
we would model the other service
organizations or service institutions on
that sort of like military pipeline
um and everybody would serve and you
know uh college would be semi paid for
or whatever right I haven't haven't done
the math you know but like right now
there's a path to it making make sense
yeah yeah and especially in this
polarizing times right
um what about the media like you keep
mentioning polarized times and I think
people think of like oh my neighbor like
what are their politics but the media
has like a very unique
um perspective but also role like you
get to see so many different news
stories right and you specifically went
to many of the most dangerous places in
the world uh you used to go with a rifle
now you're going with a camera yeah
which is like you know in some ways
crazier than going with the rifle
um how did you think about that as you
started to get deeper and deeper into
working with the media telling some of
these stories but I think in the
beginning I had a sort of semi naive
sort of non-corporate approach to Media
I had had these experiences overseas I
thought they were on the bleeding edge
of some of the most important issues
both nationally and both domestically
and internationally
um and I I felt like it was part of my
continued Legacy and service to have
those kind of conversations and to to to
show sort of what was happening to the
American public right um you know so I
was the first Western journalist in
Mogadishu in more than a decade I was
first person to have myself waterboarded
on TV you know I was in Afghanistan
um in 2005 doing a documentary series
um all of those things kind of the
Common Thread common DNA was I thought
these are important issues and like
these are the topics that Americans
should be most informed on as as we're
having com National conversations about
what to do whether it's is waterboarding
torture should we continue the war in
Afghanistan
um should we you know be paying more
attention to what's happening in places
in East Africa and West Africa so that
was really the Genesis it was mission
driven in the beginning my media career
uh as I became more sophisticated and
learned more about the institution like
I really started to understand the sort
of corporate side of media
um and my you know the brief trajectory
of my media career is I started at a
startup called current TV Al Gore's TV
network yeah create the internet
Uncle Al was was was pioneering and uh
so and and that was kind of like a short
form TV program uh ahead of its time
non-linear cable programming format
um and I went from I was then poached by
CNN and I was correspondent for their
special investigations and documentary
unit I was ingloriously fired from CNN
when they cut the entire department uh
tell us the story you know it's it's a
really weird story and I'll just say see
it as a different organization now under
different leadership but basically I was
I was uh I had been mobilized out of the
reserves out of my reserve unit and I
was in West Africa
um in uniform in the middle of the
Jungle in Liberia actually and I got a
call from like my boss at CNN and uh he
said hey they've they've cut the special
investigations and documentary unit like
you're under contract
um you can come back and go cover like
you know fires in LA or whatever but
like basically like that's it like you
know half the department got fired so uh
I got let go and so I then made what is
either like the most brilliant or the
dumbest like career move uh when it
comes to my immediate thing uh I get a
call from uh from this guy with a
British accents saying like hey I'm a
big fan I watched your work and
um you know I saw that CNN just you know
laid off it's um special in its
investigative unit
um I'd like to do a media piece about
this and I was like who is this again
he's like oh there's like John Oliver
from The Daily Show and so then John
Oliver and I created for the Daily Show
a piece um called investigating
investigative journalism basically
skewering CNN for firing its
investigative journalism it does have
like in hindsight it does sound
ridiculous right that like they would do
that at the time obviously there's money
and economics and all this stuff at play
but it is hilarious that's exactly what
it is and the truth is that long-form
investigative international news maybe
news in general has always had to be a
loss leader because the media in general
and this is sort of the meat and the
substance of it has a real monetization
problem right like the current way
especially in the digital landscape that
media is monetized is through clicks
eyeballs and AD Revenue right it's
always changing it's always Dynamic but
the basic thing is you know newspapers
create content and sell ads against them
sell digital ads against them whether
that's on Facebook or wherever else
right in some ways like all that news
that's coming through on your Facebook
feed I call like photograph journalism
they're kind of like stuffing it down
your throat Facebook you know until very
recently was really monetizing against
that and so the overall meta effect that
it had meta all puns intended you know
the meta effect of that right is that
you know and we all know this there's
nothing profound about it is that
today's current media landscape that
information is incentivized from a
monetary perspective for salaciousness
and clicks click bait right they're
incentivized for salaciousness not for
truth there's not a monetization model
around truth and investigation at least
not like a large monetization model and
this is actually the history at least in
television the history of television
news right the FCC
gave the three big networks The Big
Three ABC NBC uh CBS these incredibly
valuable Broadband Spectrum right when
they started Broadcast News right when
they started broadcast cable like the
old rabbit ear antennas right the FCC
gave them this this spectrum and they
said okay we're going to give you this
valuable radio spectrum right that you
can broadcast your television programs
on and you can you know sell ads and and
all of this stuff on it right but here's
the catch we are going to mandate right
an FCC mandate that for one hour a day
you do programming that informs the
American public and that's the Genesis
of the Nightly News hour so you know Tom
Brokaw and all those guys benefited from
this Clause that the FCC had that the
big three had to do this one hour of
like nightly Network news programming
that informed the American public and
that existed for Generations until kind
of the digital Revolution and the Advent
of 24 hours our cable news and now we're
in this era of sort of atomization of of
news and information everywhere right so
like you know uh back then CNN made you
know everything's Reinventing and
transforming and eating itself
exactly right but back then you know
like CNN disrupted The Big Three model
right and now you have digital sort of
disrupting that cable news model and
we're just in this incredibly fractured
news and information ecosystem I I
describe it as having the effect it's as
if somebody hit Mercury with a
sledgehammer and that's how our
information environment is right now and
all of the things that we thought were
supposed to bring us closer together and
connect us like social media platforms
and stuff what we're realizing now at
least in this current iteration of it is
that it's actually having the effect of
siloing us and driving us apart right
yeah um one of the big challenges I
think that we're facing as a society is
this sort of tribalism that's coming
from the ghettos nation of news and
information and this is a tough problem
to solve there are not a lot of easy
solutions for it um and I think you see
the permutations and the second and
third order effects of that playing out
throughout our culture throughout our
politics uh and that's that's where
we're living these days man yeah when I
think of your media career there's two
specific moments I want to talk about
the first is uh when you got
waterboarded on television so uh we
didn't know each other at this time but
um I was in Iraq when all of the uh um
kind of the initial papers came out and
the enhanced interrogation techniques
and like all this and you can imagine
we're like somebody had the internet
right he was like what happened and so
the waterboarding stuff uh came out and
uh I remember a guy walked in uh it's a
little area we're all sitting and he was
like what is it he's like well how hard
could that [ __ ] be and we went
outside and like literally laid down and
now it wasn't the same thing in terms of
uh the feet above the head or whatever
but we basically laid down put a towel
or someone's head poured water how long
did you go right and it turns into a
competition and guys are like timing and
of course no one lasts more than like 20
seconds yeah right but it's like in our
heads we were like idiot kids
essentially or I was 20 or 21 years old
screwing around trying to pass time you
know in the middle of our Rock and then
you did it on national television and I
and I think that at some point like I
don't think any of us knew who you were
or that you were doing anything but like
I remember just being like oh [ __ ]
somebody from uniform went and did a
national television yeah and in some
ways it was like like started from the
bottom now we're here right like
somebody pulled it off but the media and
like I think the nation in general was
like oh [ __ ] like somebody is actually
going to show us what this is it's like
how did that happen that was my first
big like breakout piece right and and
just you were viral before viral was a
thing yeah so early this whole thing is
making me sound prehistoric you know
still alive uh that and just to be fair
that was the second time I'd been
waterboarded I had been waterboarded
into your training you know and it was
so you knew what it was I knew what it
was and that first time you know you
know it's here which is this you know
survival evasion resistance Escape that
you have all this stuff you're not
supposed to tell or whatever they put me
on that water board and I'm like I'm a
Seal Seal Team One what do you want to
know what do you want to know it's
pretty bad as you know as you experience
well to be clear uh the watered down
version uh no pun intended is uh uh all
it made me think was I forget the
gentleman's name uh they was in
Guantanamo they uh they waterboard my
180 two times or something KSM can we
shake Muhammad yeah and all I kept
thinking to myself was like dude maybe I
could survive one or two like if you had
to do it 181 times like I'd be telling
you anything you want to eat right side
note they they are not sure that they
ever broke KSM they like to find them as
like a super resistor or whatever really
interesting interesting dude still down
there at at gitmo yeah architecture 911
and all that stuff
um so uh yeah so I like how why uh sir
your idea or somebody else's idea 100 my
idea yeah I figured yeah um and there's
like two funny stories that that come
out of it like uh the first is uh at CNN
that was the first time I was on
national TV okay right and so uh
Anderson Cooper you know I consider a
friend good journalist he came from the
same kind of like investigative DNA
background that that I did Anderson
called me up after the piece and he's
like he's like gosh that's it's amazing
that you pulled this off like I he asked
me the same thing you did like how did
you do it you know he's like because
I've been looking into it for a while
and you know all I could find was like
these like you know weird s m groups to
do it to me and I was like it's the
world you walk in Anderson you know I
think that's uh you should definitely
have them come do it on National
Television exactly
uh but um no look basically the the
impetus was this that debate was raging
in the National Security Community guys
like you and I and within the military
it had sort of trickled out and was
bubbling up and people are saying like
should we be doing this is it Torture
John McCain had actually kind of gone to
war with the White House
um I was a a big John McCain fan you
know he came and spoke when I was plebe
at the Navy Academy I had read the book
about a nightingale song and I had
tremendous amount of respect for what he
had been through and obviously they talk
about McCain and those guys at Sears
school right A lot of the stuff is
modeled on what those guys went through
at the Hanoi Hilton so I thought he was
a really credible voice in this debate
um and so this this debate was happening
and I would see the White House like
doing talking points I'd see McCain kind
of raging about them and then I'd see
all the
pundits you know sort of saying stuff
and I was like this is the most surreal
bizarre debate because we're talking
about this thing that nobody's ever seen
and like doesn't really have any
experience with except for guys like us
so I was like look let's just let's just
open the kimono and and show people what
it is since we're having the debate and
I thought that's how I could best be of
service and and for me it was it was a
moral position that if we're going to
have informed debates like we need to
know what we're talking about and that's
where I saw my value of bridging these
two worlds between the military and the
media when you're like all right cool I
think that we should do it on television
uh and you call the producer or whoever
like what's are they like hell yeah like
let's do it or are they like let's call
the lawyers and make sure that like you
know something doesn't go wrong actually
all everybody said no the lawyers
everybody this is sort of a story lost
to history or whatever but you know who
said yes was Al was Al Gore really Al
thought it was important and he overrode
all of the lawyers that that I think the
CEO or the CEO of the company definitely
overrode The General Counsel the GC of
the company said like no this is too
important like let kaj do it and that
was the Genesis of it I don't think I've
ever even told that story to anyone ever
um but that's how it happened the
lawyers are there they're supposed to be
the risk Killers right like hey this is
pretty damn risky
and to some degree uh do you feel like
it changed the conversation I just
people saw it I do I do like you know uh
in in journalism your wins are few and
far between right especially these days
right so I'll I'm happy to like you know
hang hang my hat a little bit on on that
one and say like I think that was
fundamentally different it also sparked
a whole series of of media coverage
around it so there was there was a lot
that happened from kind of like throwing
that stone in the lake and watching the
ripple effect I I mean up to in
including several other pieces another
Emmy nominated piece that I did where I
interviewed uh Jim Mitchell who I
consider a friend he was the architect
of that enhanced interrogation program
um I interviewed him he had never spoken
before he had personally waterboarded
Colleen Sheikh Mohammed those 180 odd
times he was the guy who did it and this
is really important because I don't
think people actually understand as part
of the enhanced interrogation techniques
uh there was the waterboarding which I
think probably took the in the coverage
and it was something that uh it's easy
to now see on television or on movies
and and uh kind of gets recreated over
and over again uh but there was also
things like uh they told one of uh one I
think it was a one of the guys uh he was
really scared of insects and so they
told him they were like uh uh hey if
this insect bites you it'll kill you
right and they put them in a box uh
which is essentially like almost like a
coffin size box or whatever and they put
the insect in there and it was not a
poisonous you know killer insect but to
some degree uh truth is what you believe
right and so this dude definitely
thought that they were gonna kill him
right and so it brought up the debate of
like actually not only is there the
physical component of it but the
psychological component as well and
waterboarding is unique and it has both
of them to some degree
um and so like that whole time was like
weird because I think it's hard for
people to recognize uh something that um
from the outside
idiot we put you in a box and like
there's an insect that can't do anything
to you on the other end it's like
there's a psychological component there
that's pretty powerful it totally
completely and and I think these were
fundamental questions especially at that
time like what techniques are
appropriate to use like where do we draw
the line right um obviously John McCain
was adamantly against anything that that
broached up to the line of torture
um and and I think that that was
important I think for you and I who who
both served right I deep to our sort of
core ideology and sense of self that we
served honorably right we both like on
our DD214 the paper you get when you
discharge have that making a giant
assumption here that we both have
honorable discharges I don't know about
you but I do but yes
all right good glad we got that out of
the way right like that honorable
discharge is really important to me and
I want my my time in uniform to be
remembered honorably
um and so things that can impugn that
um sometimes they're they're necessary
or things that have the potential to
impute that
um so look there's there was at the time
and still is like a robust National no
debate on how we sort of gain
intelligence and information I think
this was an important thing and as part
of that ripple effect you know I I put
Jim Mitchell on TV for the first time
talking from his perspective and I think
I gave him a a really fair Shake
although a weird Shake I interviewed him
uh here in Florida
um on a canoe surrounded by alligators
because I thought it was a great
metaphor for how he saw the world yeah
right and that that piece also got
nominated for an Emmy and that piece led
to a movie with Adam Driver and Annette
Benning called the report which was
about this subject so
um look most of the ninety percent of
the things you do in journalism kind of
go out there into The Ether and don't
affect policy or don't affect the
national discourse like like anything
else you just you know sort of keep
plugging I do think that one helped
shape the national discourse so so I'm
proud of it yeah the other uh moment uh
that I recently was reminded of uh close
award from CNN was uh in Afghanistan
during the Afghan pull out uh and I
think the nation or at least folks that
I talked to on a daily basis they were
very surprised to see a woman there
surrounded by the Taliban and she's like
interviewing them right and it was uh
this weird uh kind of cognitive
dissonance of like everything that they
had assumed or thought about uh was
being shaken but also they understood
that like this is a very dangerous
situation why because she's literally oh
wait uh they're shooting at somebody you
know and she's like talking about this
live and what it reminded me of is uh
you did a piece with Vice very early on
I think uh where you were actually in uh
I think it was a plane and it was uh in
Nigeria with Boko Haram and for whatever
reason it was probably one of a bunch of
pieces of early advice that I'd watched
but I remember this because you're like
uh another shooting at uh Ramen there's
like a guy hanging out on the side with
like a uh machine gun he's just like pkf
yeah and you're like like you can just
tell like you're much more comfortable
than I think like a normal journalist
would be yeah and so like in those
situations like it's one thing with
current TV and like Hey we're gonna
waterboard you but it's somewhat of a
controlled environment and like it's on
National Television but like you know
what you're getting yourself into going
into these conflict zones very different
like whether it's Clarissa whether it's
you uh doing some of the stuff like how
did you think about like when to say yes
and like did you ever say actually I
don't think that that's one that we
should go do for whatever reason yeah
absolutely for me like the great white
whale you know the stories that got away
are are just the ones that I I didn't
get to do for for whatever reason uh you
know anything any operation any Mission
any journalism assignment that I tried
to do is always a risk benefit calculus
and there are just some times where it's
not worth it and then there are other
times where you push the envelope I
remember there was this former problem
of somali's uh fleeing to Yemen
um during their
unfortunately now we're reverse
migration because Yemen's one of the
most dangerous places in the world so
somalis actually returning to Somalia
um for a while because Mogadishu and the
rest of Somalia was so dangerous they
were uh there were Somali refugees like
taking these boats across the uh the the
Sea of eight inner the Red Sea
um to the yemeni coast and they were
somebody had told me someone a friend
from the humanitarian from the human
rights Community had told me that you
could go to a beach in Yemen and set up
cameras and that bodies would just wash
up on the beach and it sounded
apocryphal it sounded like something
like yeah right people say that stuff
but they're being hyperbolic no I went
there and it was like absolutely true
because these boats were so rickety and
shaky bringing these refugees across in
somalis as we said earlier don't really
swim that well quite often uh they like
the boats were capsizing they're
drowning and you just set up a camera on
the beach and you'd wait till morning
till sunrise bodies would just wash up
uh on on the beach so I was trying to
get a Smuggler to take me on one of the
boats to go across
um and uh
yeah I can't remember I think it was
like a two-day Journey or something so
you couldn't swim like you yourself
wouldn't be able to probably swim well I
wouldn't go that far
given it was you know no no no not
swimmable yeah not swimmable quite
Sharky all of that all of that stuff um
I think most of these people were
drowning with inside of shore
um and the reason being is that the
yemeni Coast Guard was patrolling at the
time the Smugglers would jump in would
dump them and and and go I don't think
people actually uh understand this
specific situation uh I I don't know
anything about but um even on the
American uh borders right when you look
at some of these videos and and I've
talked to people who are uh border
patrol and things like that around
um these rivers that they're Crossing
like
if you were a person who didn't have a
reason to go across that was life or
death or you wanted to get to America or
something like that but you probably
wouldn't cross right like like they're
dangerous things to do and we're talking
about walking in many cases or swimming
across a river that you can see the
other side you're talking about here of
like basically going on a two-day voyage
and like hope we're heading in the right
direction oh yeah with like 300 people
crammed in the conditions were supposed
to be atrocious
um so and you know the reason that I
wanted to do a story like that um
obviously the story has has changed many
years later is like you know just
there's a human component to that and
again like we're talking about all of
these policies and all of these ideas
and I think especially in policy like I
have a masters in policy right I I get
the policy world but quite often we lose
the human Dynamic and the human factor
and that's where where journalism and
and cameras and filmmaking and
storytelling can sort of bring us closer
to the reality of a situation and I
wouldn't ask anybody to cross the Red
Sea in a raft with Somali refugees but I
do think that the power in its highest
form in its most altruistic form that's
what good journalism can be how did you
convince cameraman to go with you or did
you sometimes just say if I could give
me the camera and I'll uh I'll be back I
I every once in a while I've done that
like that that uh that was actually a
hind helicopter that you're describing
in uh in Northern Nigeria every once in
a while I've had to shoot it myself like
the cameraman on that one went home it
was it was very dangerous but you know
in in all these communities in the world
like I think For Better or For Worse
guys like you and me find like-minded
people right so I was doing uh stunts on
uh water stunts on the Jack Ryan series
kind of like a side hustle fun hobby of
mine is to do stunt work occasionally
and uh uh and I and I was sitting with
this like crew of stuntman like you know
um as we're preparing to do a stunt and
I was like oh these guys are just like
frogmen you know if there was no rules
about like you know a felony convictions
or college degrees or anything like that
it's this the same sort of adventurous
risk-taking DNA
um I and I always thought like it's it's
amazing that's why I loved the Seal team
so much and so close to to the guys that
I served with I love when when you take
that Gene that like adrenaline chasing
you know Call it Courage whatever that
ingredient whatever that human quality
is and then you Channel it for a mission
and purpose um and I think that's the
real Secret Sauce the real secret power
of the Special Operations Community
um and it frankly it multiplies out to
the conventional Services as well
anybody who is willing uh to put
themselves In Harm's Way or to take risk
for uh for a higher purpose you know
that that goes a long way in my book but
there's a a story that I didn't know
until recently uh Dakota Meyer oh yeah
Dakota's great so he um he told the
story in a way where uh for those who
don't know
um he uh was awarded honor uh him and a
driver drove back and forth into a
village under heavy fire the rest of
their life all stuff uh but he told the
kind of pre-story before those actions
and basically he was going to be on a
mission he gets told uh he was basically
raising too many concerns and kind of
giving people a hard time supposedly and
said hey why don't you just go sit up
there and let us go do the mission and
uh when he gets in the truck he
basically says to the driver hey [ __ ]
may go bad today uh when it does get the
[ __ ] out of the driver's seat and I'm
gonna go save them and the driver who in
many cases uh these you know Humvees and
stuff they're not actual uh just the
driver right they have other
responsibilities whatever he was like
you're not going anywhere without me
right and there's this element of uh I
think a lot about like courage is
contagious as well and so uh when you
see one person do it all of a sudden
everyone is like well we can all do it
right and I do think that's part of the
beauty of the military in general but
also the Special Operations Community is
that like you just need one person to be
like guys we can do this yeah next thing
you know everyone's like well [ __ ] yeah
let's go do it yeah okay guys you might
think that okay X
sounds like a new genius football
formation it's actually not Charlie it's
your new favorite crypto trading app
you heard the man
so true and so inspiring also the Contra
positive is true like I uh so is
fearfulness right and I remember in buds
like you know so many lessons are sort
of forged there on the sand
um guys rarely quit alone wow I did not
do that yes you'll be sitting there in
the surf locked arm and arm middle of
the night everybody's jackhammering
because their body's so cold it's trying
to generate heat or whatever and the
bell that ordering like gold Bell is
right over there and you'll see like
guys Whispering like hey like I'll quit
if you quit kind of thing no way and
then they just start sprinting in twos
for the Bell right so I I I I I I I I I
totally heed your point and honor it and
I'm adding an additional point that it
works both ways yeah I never thought of
it that way but that is fascinating and
so what's the lesson there right like
like careful who you surround yourself
with yeah yeah yeah absolutely do you
see um Jack Carr's uh journalist yeah
what'd you think of it uh I thought it
was good right like oh look I I'm happy
whenever anybody is able to take their
experience I tried to do this myself
chafe their experience and evolve into a
new chapter and be in the sort of
creative industry it's like do I think
the plot line like as like you know a
still you know you know Lieutenant
Commander in the SEAL Teams right like
do I think that Lieutenant commanders
are going rogue and like killing their
own platoons like I do not like that
part's a little Preposterous but in
terms of like it makes it for a good
book
yeah yeah yeah I just want to say like
we are not doing that like the dudes
that I served with the Admirals that I
served with like are some among the
finest Americans I've ever met in my
whole life um but yeah look it's so
awesome to see Jack
pseudonym
Jack uh to see him Thrive and succeed in
the creative Endeavors and you know have
a that's Amazon right yes yeah yeah you
know to have like on a big streaming
outlet and like all of these accolades
and
um uh yeah like it's on you man one of
the things that I took away from it was
uh I knew that a lot of uh military
veterans were doing uh training for
movies and things like that and um I
always joke that like if you ever watch
a movie and like somebody's like holding
a gun the wrong way or whatever like
yeah
um and uh and now there's even a whole
vein of I don't know if you've seen a
lot of uh uh seals and Special Forces
guys whatever they do reaction videos on
YouTube oh yeah and they're like that's
just not really yeah yeah
um but this one was one I thought very
well done but also two I was like oh
[ __ ] like I never thought about all
these lived experiences that people had
for 20 years like they are going to come
to books they're going to come to movies
they're going to come to these uh media
platforms that I think most Americans
haven't seen that stuff in a long time
now was the time right there was there
wasn't like a bunch of great Vietnam
movies right Apocalypse Now like didn't
get made until you know a decade after
Vietnam right like there takes some
cultural maturation that has to happen
for all these products and I mean some
of it is just like us getting out of the
service and finding our legs in the
civilian World
um and but like I think that that time
period is is now happening like and it's
also like a time of reflection right in
some ways we've wound down we've
certainly wound down Afghanistan
um but and like we've wound down the
global war on terror in fact they I just
read that the uh I think the National
Defense ribbon as an automatic I
remember that sort of like participation
ribbon that everybody gets you know the
National Defense ribbon because we're in
a time of War I think that's going away
as an automatic you know signaling that
we are ebbing from the global war on
terror um and so I think now is a time
for reflection on the two longest Wars
in American history
um culture pop culture are some of the
the best ways to do it you know and I'm
proud of of guys like like Jack Carr
um you know being able to use the
creative Industries to do that kind of
Storytelling like we're certainly not
the only voice and the only lived
experience in America
um but you know over over two million of
us in uniform during the you know Iraq
and Afghanistan Wars like we're we're a
part of the fabric of American society
yeah when you think of kind of your post
uh military career uh you did a lot of
what I'll call the the war correspondent
and media work uh now you have uh I
would from my outside view uh kind of
three different looks you have uh some
humanitarian work things like team
Rubicon and others uh you still uh go to
some of these areas so uh I believe
you've gone to Ukraine a couple of times
now
um and then you also are participating
in Building Technology and products and
stuff like that that kind of Shadow
align between Great Tech products but
also help the military Community I
thought maybe we could just kind of talk
through each one of those and the
humanitarian piece to me is uh something
that isn't surprising but uh you have a
very wide variety of of uh things that
you participate in uh from uh swimming
to uh the team Rubicon let's like talk
through a little bit as to like some of
that work and like why choose some of
the things you've chosen to do yeah yeah
well I'll I'll just caveat that like
Ukraine was a total aberration okay I
did not intend to go to Ukraine I uh you
know I I got out of the seal reserves in
2017.
um I thought I was done going to war I
made this transition as you indicated
from the media into money right where I
have this this fintech company that I'm
super proud of
um and I really thought I was done in
fact I was two months into my startup uh
when I had the really wonderful
conversation with my co-founder like hey
I know we just launched this this great
new startup Guild like things are you
know humming along things are awesome
but like we're so early stage that we've
never even talked about vacation policy
but everybody gets vacation right so I'm
gonna take my vacation and take a little
sabbatical and go to Ukraine because I
feel morally compelled to do so so but
what it does the the Ukraine Mission uh
does fit into this like kind of my
portfolio is really divided in in half
it's my and and the Venn diagram
overlaps a lot there's the humanitarian
um service oriented work that I do my
philanthropic work and I did that for a
decade it helped start an organization
using my combat pay called the mission
continues that led to and served on the
board there uh that was about giving
veterans a sense of purpose and and
giving them an opportunity to do public
service and then that led to us giving a
grant to team Rubicon to start team
Rubicon I also sat on the board at Team
Rubicon again humanitarian work in
disaster zones so I spent
uh and now I'm part of a team called
Force blue which takes former combat
divers repurposes their skills for ocean
conservation uh it's awesome it's
actually based right here in Miami we're
all we all became scientific divers for
the frost Science Center downtown here
in Miami so we go out we do coral
restoration we do
um uh turtle rescue missions
um it's it's pretty it's pretty awesome
yeah like as a frogman it gets me back
in the water with a sense of mission and
purpose so I have this I've for for the
last decade concurrent with my media
career in parallel I've been really
oriented in the veterans service space
um and and I've spent a decade trying to
give veterans a sense of mission and
purpose but what I've come to realize in
this this next chapter in my life
um and we started this company this uh
this past Veterans Day on we launched on
November 11th and so we're coming up on
our that was our beta but we're coming
up on essentially our one year
anniversary what I started to realize is
that sense of veterans purpose is really
important
and it's what economists call necessary
but not sufficient oh interesting if we
are not just giving veterans a sense A
Renewed sense of mission and purpose but
we're not also paying attention to their
purse and to their sense of Financial
Security their sense of financial
stability their long-term Financial
Health and Wellness like all the mission
stuff in the world isn't gonna matter
right and all the problems that we hear
in the military community in the
veterans community
um a lot of those are magnified by this
lack of financial stability and planning
like
um and Financial Health and Wellness and
lack of financial literacy so basically
the way it started for me is like you
know the the analog here is like you
know people talk about
you know meditation and there's a lot of
talk in the wellness space like you and
I are big Fitness Buffs right like I do
a lot in the fitness space I owned a
CrossFit gym for many years right like
that's like that's how I keep my knife
sharp you know is by is by pushing the
envelope physically
um and even a lot of the veterans events
are like you know swims around the
Hudson and all of that stuff it's all
part of like keeping my my mind body
sharp
um but when I think in the wellness
space there's all this talk about
mindfulness and meditation really
important stuff really valuable stuff
but you can go meditate for 30 minutes
in the morning and then if you come back
to like a trove of credit card companies
right telling you how much debt you have
like all of that mindfulness and all of
that Zen is out the window and in the
military Community I don't know what
your transition was like but in large
part the military Community has been
left behind by the private wealth
Community without a doubt right when you
got out of the service right did you do
Taps yeah the transition program uh I
think when we came back
for my rock there was like a yellow
ribbon program yeah and it was like a
day yeah and it was like bring your
families and like everyone like showed
up I was like all right I was sat in
like an auditorium uh they tried like to
be fair it was uh very well intentioned
but uh it's hard when you're talking to
a room full of I don't know a couple
hundred people uh and every single
person is literally completely different
like how do you talk to uh the commander
and the you know private first class
about the same issues like it's just
different and it's it starts at day one
when we enter the military right the uh
I'm sure you're aware they've changed
the retirement system in the military
right so you enter the military you're
17 you're 18 years old you know you're a
recruit you're going to boot camp
um and then you get to your you know
your first training station or your
first Duty station right and it's hard
in general to get 17 and 18 year olds to
think about their long-term financial
future right I I bet I'm just gonna go
out on a live here and say you either
have a personal story or like some
friends who did some pretty stupid
things with their money I remember being
in Iraq uh and there was I don't know
how old the kid was he was young and
like he's like I have no money
and and we were like dude like
everything you're earning here is
tax-free up to whatever point you know
87 whatever uh what do you mean you have
no money and he was like walked you
through his financial decisions and you
were like if you wrote down like
everything not to do like this kid
checked every single box and like
thankfully the military was giving them
food and a place to sleep and like all
this stuff but I was like Wow and it was
just like very egregious things and then
you realize like yeah this kid has never
he's never been in this position before
and no one's ever told him not even uh
what to do to grow wealth just like how
do you understand to spend less than you
make right right I mean like these
simple simple stuff simple budgeting
yeah right and there is that financial
literacy Gap is huge and I think we saw
it over and over and the the bad news is
that there are a lot of forces aligned
against military members when it comes
to finances right so let me explain a
couple of them well you know just first
and foremost there's a pay Gap really
relative to their sort of Civilian
counterparts um you know the second is
um you know there's been a change in the
military retirement system right so you
know what used to be a defined benefit
system has gone to a contribution-based
system so the tsp right that's not
necessarily bad
um but you're asking 17 and 18 year olds
now to make complex decisions about
their financial future without the
preparation and the financial literacy
that's required for it
um and then there's just like a
predatory environment so I went to jump
school back then the Army owned the air
pipeline so I went to jump school at
Fort Benning Georgia were you ever there
like uh you never got to Benning okay
but it's like every other military base
with a Ville on the outside you know the
Ville right so you walk outside the the
gates and there's what is it strip clubs
uh tattoo parlors some payday loans and
a used car dealership right so I mapped
from Fort Benning Georgia where I went
to basic parachuted school to the first
from the main gate to the first used car
dealership with an over 20 percent
interest rate 0.7 miles you can walk if
you don't have a car from the main gates
of Fort Benning Georgia to that first
used car dealership and get your new
Mustang because you have like a regular
government paycheck gotta get that
Mustang right
20 interest right and people have no
idea they don't understand compounding
interest rate they don't understand
um what what that effect is so there's
this also this predatory environment out
there right there's cultural there's
predatory headwinds and even in like
today's day and age like we look at
inflation right inflation has hit the
military Community harder than the
civilian Community partially because our
pay raises our pay rates are set by
Congress right and that takes a
political process to change our sort of
economic equivalence blue collar workers
who might be in unions and stuff can
pivot they can chart change their
contracts they can do things to adjust
with the pace of inflation faster than
the military did right in addition to
just a sort of lower wages in general
and the size I think a lot of people
forget the size of the military uh uh
kind of Base when you make one two
percent adjustments it's a lot of money
swing you know the swing of amount of
capital that is now going to be
allocated from a budget standpoint is
very large right so actually you know
the admission in Congress passed a 3.7
percent military pay raise uh this year
sounds good right but inflation's
running at nine percent so the military
to my mind got a six percent pay cut
this year and so uh so you see this
environment and it and it's it's
translating into all kinds of things
right 84 percent of military families
cite Financial stress as the number one
household issue wow um you know the Army
is going to miss its recruiting goal by
half this year by half right so there's
all these second and third order effects
of it and luckily DOD is waking up to
this reality in fact I I just saw that
um I think it was The Joint Chiefs
helped you know push through this
augmented bill that will help keep
military members above the poverty line
wow this is a sad day when our uniform
members are living below the poverty
line
um so the the environment is tough the
the dod has not sufficiently prepared uh
young military members and Veterans
military Community
um in terms of Financial Health and
Wellness so because I had spent all this
time in veteran service and with this
mission of helping veterans I I realized
that my my new calling my new purpose
was to really embark on this path to
help close that wealth Gap right the
best way to do it is is or one of the
good ways to do it is through financial
Education and Training in the other is
through investing
um so I created this platform uh along
with two other naval officers
um two Navy Intel officers actually
because you know we needed some big
brains and not just a Paleolithic
knuckle dragger you know you need it all
to to be successful right yeah Intel
drives operations you know
um so no my co-founder is 20-year Wall
Street veteran
um we we looked at we looked at this pay
Gap where we looked at this this wealth
gap between the military and civilian
Community uh and we saw that there was
no company out there serving the
military for private wealth um you would
have thought that USAA traditionally had
that market locked up I'm a USAA member
in fact I just bought homeowners
insurance
through USAA this morning right uh I
actually love USAA I think they're
they're they're awesome but uh you know
a couple years ago they sold off their
investing arm to Charles Schwab right so
you literally go on the USAA website
click invest it'll redirect you to the
Charles Schwab website no affiliation
with the military community so we saw a
need out there for a company that had
military ingrained in its DNA to help
um
increase the Financial Health and
Wellness in the military community so
our our big Over the Horizon North Star
goal is to raise 50 billion dollars in
wealth for the military Community we do
that by getting you know several million
military members and their families
um investing accounts worth you know if
we can get all of those families to get
ten thousand dollars worth of an
investment account will achieved our
goal the way we do it is the same way
you know we do it in the military right
like through training and education and
we actually believe in this so much so
we've created a curriculum on our
platform a knowledge curriculum and that
has simple things on it like savings
versus investing what your buddy who had
no money in Iraq really the video he
really needed to I don't know if I want
to claim buddy status
a colleague
your battle buddy yeah
the what you know what that 58 second
video you if he had watched that and
answered two simple questions on savings
versus investing we'd put five dollars
in his brokerage account to start to
invest so what the platform is
essentially is a self-directed investing
platform fractional share zero
commissions and we're trying to get
people started on that investing Journey
right so that they can have build
long-term Financial Health and law and
what's fascinating is uh one just
telling someone hey you can do this
right it is incredibly empowering but
the second thing is uh understanding the
perspective they're coming from I think
it is uh um an underrated thing in these
scenarios because people like oh okay
the military whatever like there are
certain things that these people will go
through uh divorce is a incredibly High
rate in the military especially with
young military members versus uh kind of
their civilian peers
um and when you start thinking about all
of these components that actually are
Financial uh aspects of their life
um
realizing that and being able to build a
product uh it makes sense that of course
people are going to flow there they say
hey you you understand me you have the
products that I need uh and if you can
just get in front of them and get them
there then why wouldn't it work today's
episode is brought to you by ftxus
they're a safe regulated way to buy
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've got
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
percent cheaper than their competitors
there's also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately FTX us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code pop and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today 100 and
look to be clear our platform's open to
anybody like by in investing by holding
your portfolio on the guild platform you
support the military community and one
of the ways you do that is our
curriculum that knowledge curriculum I
was talking about is literally some of
it some of it is good General Financial
advice but we have a whole tab called
military money that's designed
specifically for the circumstances you
just mentioned like you know how to read
your leave-in earnings statement right
uh you know how to invest in the tsp or
what happens if you PCS if you change
your station right you know a lot of
military folks are are being moved to a
different area you know 18 months 24
year three year Cycles like much more
frequently than their civilian
counterparts and those have as you said
those are really have economic
implications right so our we have an
entire section of our knowledge
curriculum training and education
devoted just to military specific
circumstances
um yeah and so so the platform is
completely open it's a fintech platform
that uh anyone can use so whether you
are a service member or you're not you
can use it and really the idea is for
the service members there are uh now uh
all of these different features and
products that uh other fintech
applications have but they are
specifically designed with you in mind
and kind of serve the needs that you
have but also if you are not in the
military and you simply want to support
the military you can go ahead and use
this application uh and some of the
resources and and time and energy of
that team and stuff is going to help the
military as well that's that's exactly
it and um you know we like to say and
I've fundamentally believe that money
moves at the speed of trust people will
invest their money they'll hold their
money they'll let other people be
custodians of their portfolios with
people that they trust and for me
there's a large trust Gap in the
financial Market especially with the
military and look I don't expect anybody
to invest on our platform just because
we wore the uniform and our our military
folks trust doesn't work that way trust
is earned right what we do think is that
through through our experience and
through the platform itself you'll see
that trust and one of the things where
I'll put our platform up against any of
the other you know apps and companies
out there where people there are lots of
places to hold their that people can
hold their money right and and some of
them are are quite excellent and the are
because we have a social Mission just to
help the military community in general
like the most important thing for me is
to get military
personnel and Veterans investing in
their future whether you do that on our
platform or another platform is fine one
of the things that I believe increases
the the trust of of our platform is not
just that we all served in the military
and we have this shared experience but
also the platform itself right is built
around trust and transparency so if you
think about the two biggest barriers to
entry for investing it's people think
they don't have enough money and even if
they did they don't know where to invest
their money you know you break down that
we don't have enough money by doing
fractional by allowing fractional share
investing so you can start investing
with as little as a dollar right
um and so that sort of takes that out of
the equation and then the other pieces
the knowledge piece and we talked about
the the knowledge curriculum but the
sort of Third Leg of the triangle there
is is trust and transparency and so one
of the one of the features the way our
platform is designed is that everybody
comes on they get an anonymous username
um and actually you'll see they also
hashtag so you'll see people grouping by
like hashtag Army hashtag Navy Seals
right so you can actually check out on
our platform how the Army portfolio how
all the hashtag RV folks are are
performing but you get this just just
tell us who's outperforming who I've
[Laughter]
I remember we walked by some Air Force
guys and uh they had very very very nice
uh area to stay in and uh one of them
said a comment that just I will forever
never uh forgive anyone in the Air Force
they were like oh yeah if we had to stay
with you guys we would get Hazard pay
and I heard being like literally like
that does look to be the truth here yeah
well I mean you know the reality is like
it's easy to get those stock tips on
your nice golf courses right
absolutely so but but there is this
grouping by service there there is
that's one of the many ways that you can
organize and there's actually some
interesting data around you know how how
these different communities are
performed but more importantly you know
so full trust and transparency like
everybody gets an anonymous username I'm
gilded frog one you can literally like
be on the platform every day we rack and
stack people and I took this straight
out of straight out of CrossFit like a
whiteboard or straight out of a Peloton
um you know we rack and stack the top
performing portfolios in the platform by
day week and month so you can literally
go on to this leaderboard right and you
can say oh there gilded frog one uh he's
number three on the leaderboard I want
to see what he's holding you can click
into there and you can see not by dollar
amount but by percentage what they're
holding in their portfolio and you can
see like wow this person like you know
like the market was down on Friday right
because of all this stuff about fed
rates and all about interest rates being
raised by the fed and stuff markets down
but you get wow this portfolio is up 11
that's that's incredible gains how like
how did they do that click in and you
can see like okay he's holding you know
like yeah XYZ of this percentage of
investment right and so you can actually
see what these people are holding so
that not only increases trust and
transparency it's it's also a learning
tool it's a peer-to-peer mentorship kind
of learning tool and if you think about
how most people are are getting their
financial advice like Reddit right or
you know I'm fascinated with the tick
tock 22 year old who is uh dropping uh
uh the knowledge of uh how that how
they're going to retire by 35 yeah no
like all of these Financial you know
YouTube Reddit you know Tick Tock all
these 300 gains all of this stuff okay
that may be true or it may not be true
and that to me is like one of like one
of the real problems with this like
ecosystem of of financial information
out there is that we don't actually have
any verification processes on what's
happening on Reddit we don't know how
true that is somebody could claim they
had these giant gains but on our
platform you can see in real time with
real conviction what people are
investing in and how they're performing
and that kind of transparency doesn't
really exist right and like you know if
you have a financial advisor right the
old like if you're such a good financial
advisor how come you're not rich right I
prefer to use Warren Buffett's uh wall
Street's the only place where people
take I think they're Bentleys to take
advice from people who ride the subway
yeah
because if Warren Buffett says then
you're not a troll then you're just
really repeating uh the financial Gods
uh comments totally or I was you know I
was actually a a guest of the buffets at
Berkshire Hathaway conference this year
you know what they call Woodstock for
capitalists yes and he said a similar
thing like you know he's got themes
right and uh and he said oh yeah um it
uh financial advisors are um people who
know you know it's like people who know
nothing about the stock market being
advised by people who know even less you
know
exactly you know so and that and that's
part of the reason that we think one
self-directed investing is important
that people have to take control of
their their financial future uh and two
that we believe that this transparency
piece is really important the ability to
look at real-time real-time conviction
of how portfolios are performing about
how people's portfolios are performing
and to use that as a as a model and a
mentorship tool and course it requires
research of course it requires people to
be educated about what they're doing but
uh it's sort of a start and we think
that differentiates us we also have a a
really interesting thing that came out
of Naval intelligence school so my
co-founder Naval intelligence officer
was at Dam Neck going through Naval
intelligence officer training school
they studied this case of the USS
scorpion which was essentially
discovered in 1968 using a collective
intelligence approach
um Goldman Sachs has a very similar
thing called the Goldman Sachs VIP index
where they use this sort of aggregation
of top performing stocks you know lots
of sort of financial products use this
kind of approach to collective
intelligence we've taken that model
we've put it on the guild platform we we
aggregate the top 30 Holdings on the
guild portfolio and it's this idea this
James sirwiki idea of the wisdom of
crowds that you know
um none of us is smarter than all of us
right and what we've seen even in this
down Market where the s p is you know
still off you know 13 on the year
um that the guild portfolio this
collective intelligence portfolio that
we have is outperforming uh the s p
pretty substantially so anyways that's
sort of like nerding out about the tools
and the wickets and the design of the
platform
um but the The Meta point is that you
know I
I think we have built the most trusted
and transparent investing platform out
there
um and it serves it's open to anyone but
it also it fund its fundamental mission
is to serve the military community and
you can make the argument uh that
there's no Community that's sort of more
deserving to you know participate in in
the growth the wealth growth of the
United States yeah and and it feels like
there's a lot of people who they simply
just want to support the military right
like there's people who say hey uh um in
like the crypto world people always ask
me like uh uh where's the decentralized
Twitter like no one's leaving Twitter
for decentralized Twitter right like it
has to be a 10x better product here
actually though uh buying stocks you can
do a lot of different platforms but I do
think that uh uh even if that's all you
did right you didn't even build
something better which I think you guys
are building something better but if you
didn't do that there's still a lot of
people who say had rather just support
the military and do it on a platform
that understands how important that
organization is to our country yeah you
know as a as a as a a tech entrepreneur
you know this well you have all these
wild ideas all these theories about how
things are going to work right and then
then you hit the bat with Jocko you know
and Jocko you know armbar crucifixions
you and like your reality comes crashing
down at least that's my left experience
right but no you have all these like
wild ideas as a tech entrepreneur and
then every once in a while
um you get sort of proof positive data
points that some of your hypotheses are
true right so we launched this company
in beta on Veterans Day last year we
went live January 1st
um and we really did it pretty front
sight focused with the military
community in mind but we had this sort
of inkling of an idea that uh people
supporters that there's this Patriot
Affinity Market out there people who
want to support the military community
and will sort of put their money where
their mouth is not as a donation like I
know this very well that people do that
from a donation World
um but from an investment perspective
that they will invest on you know
platforms like like ours and as we have
gone out and we've you know I'm speaking
to 350 Marines at Camp Pendleton the
other day like I'm speaking to the ROTC
unit at Notre Dame in in two weeks um as
I've continued to go out and stay
focused on this this core audience of
like raising the financial literacy of
the military Community
um I've learned I've seen more and more
evidence that that is true that there is
this community of supporters out there
this Patriot Affinity Market whatever
whatever you want to call it um uh that
is really really keenly interested in
investing their dollars on places that
supported the military the evidence I
have is uh you know one of the best
anecdotal pieces of evidence I have is I
was on uh my friend Carl Higby who I
served with in the SEAL Teams
um he is a morning host morning weekend
host on Newsmax
um and uh so I I told Carl like hey
there's this issue inflation is really
eating into military salaries pay
decrease you know we've we've started
this this platform uh to help military
people with their financial future
interested in talking about he said yep
please come on so uh Sunday morning I
got I was in California at the time so
like 4 30 a.m hit you know 4 30 a.m in
at 4 30 a.m late August Sunday TV hit on
Newsmax right uh and I'm talking about
Guild and uh the not only did we get you
know like 100 people signing up within
five minutes of the segment we had a
series of people who had actually
transferred their portfolios over from
Robin Hood to us right now I think
partially Robin Hood is its own story
you know they certainly were Innovative
in the space but you know they're it's
been pretty Rocky for them now if you
look at revenue and stock and and all
that stuff and so and I think there's
still a little bit of a trust hangover
in the market but literally we got email
that morning from Sunday morning late
August you know on Newsmax saying like
hey please transfer my portfolio from X
company to you guys I want to invest on
a platform that's more aligned with my
values and this was like the
waterboarding like you do all these
pieces and then every once in a while
something actually comes true and we had
been sort of like projecting this in our
mind for a long time that you know
non-military people just supporters of
the military Community
um would would want to invest on Guild
simply for for this fact and then that
email literally this morning like
they're literally that same morning you
know several of those like please please
transfer we want a company more aligned
with our values and that that that for
us was a huge win yeah I mean look it it
uh it makes sense and I think also
um it goes back to uh courage is
contagious I I think there's a whole
group of people in the United States who
uh they feel kind of uh weird about uh
voicing uh support for various causes
but then when they see their neighbor or
their friend or somebody they follow on
social media or whatever say hey I care
about this stuff and and I'm willing to
take action even if it's just
transferring my assets to a platform if
I'm going out in the community doing
something then all of a sudden it's like
oh cool I got air cover like yeah I care
about that too actually and you start to
see that build over time yeah and I
think there's like this easy sand trap
that we could get caught in on this is
that there's this political ideology or
political lens like you know um because
everything's become so polarized like
um we could think that like oh that's
just right-wing stuff right like the
anecdote that I just told you you know
from Newsmax right which like leans
right you know as a news institution or
whatever
um and like but like really what I think
that this is as a political as it gets
and I think it's the same as we thought
about in Iraq or Afghanistan when we're
going to kick in a door we didn't ask if
the person in front or behind us you're
Republican are you democrat who are you
voting for who you voted before go go go
clear right no like and I think one of
one of the best parts of the military
and why we still largely enjoy like you
know public support and institutional
support as as an organization
um is because we have been able for the
most part to operate independent of that
political lens like the independence of
the US military
um that we serve whoever the
commander-in-chief is at the time is
extraordinarily important we've tried to
bring that ethos to the guild platform
like you know supporting the military is
not a political act it's not an
ideological act right it doesn't mean
that you're partisan in any way shape or
form right I you know we were talking
about you know Al Gore's Innovation
earlier today you know coupled with uh
you know my appearance on Carl higby's
news Mass segment there those are
opposite sides of the political Spectrum
well I always uh joke that uh uh most
people forget uh a Republican or a
Democrat every four to eight years uh
becomes the leader of the military right
like right now Democratic Republican
like it'll keep switching and so the if
the leader uh has a different political
ideology uh back and forth like that's
probably a pretty good thing yeah and I
and you know this might be a bridge too
far or whatever but I there are all of
these like extraordinary lessons that I
think you and I have tried to
extrapolate from our military experience
to bring to the civilian world I think
some of the popularity of uh you know of
Jocko and some of these uh stanma
Crystal other like sort of storied
military leaders
um who are now giving you know corporate
speeches and stuff like that is that
that that there is wisdom that is
requisite in the military that adds
value to our country and our our culture
and I think this is one of those
examples the non-partisan nature of the
military if we can extrapolate that out
writ large to society
um I think we'll all I think we'll all
be better served and uh and that's
certainly the ethos that we've tried to
live at Via Guild yeah I I love the idea
and I think a lot of people who watch
this will will love it as well where can
we send people if they want to download
the app or participate yeah uh iPhone
app store uh look up guild Financial
come right up download the app
um the uh and same with Android all of
the platforms our website
guild.financial
um and yeah we we love we love having
you know new people on board it's great
we're watching this yeah we're listening
that's why you like the military kaj is
being nice Go download the app uh where
can we send people to find you on the
internet you know I have my own website
uh collegevarsen.com it's got a
repository of my my media work and and
stuff on there as well uh I do the gram
I love the gram
imagine if Instagram was out while you
were a seal oh you know oh my God I feel
like we barely like like we couldn't
even take photos in those days you know
so guys have all like you know like the
the platoon Guys these days they got all
these Glamor Shots right oh my gosh we
weren't even allowed to have cameras you
know so I don't even have that like
great stash of like cage team guy photos
yeah I think I have like maybe 12 or 15
photos like actual photos right well so
but here was the thing is uh I was there
0809 and so like when I got back
Facebook was just now like breaking out
of like the uh uh the college world and
uh I remember feeling like a freaking
badass that I gotta upload some photos
on Facebook and then I like now I'm like
I have no clue what what where photos
are any of this stuff but like there's
those 10 photos
yeah so like you have physical photos
which I think is I mean for decades
that's what people had totally totally I
I actually do still have like a like a
shoe box it's like a cliche a shoe box
of like photos from you know Buds and
you know my first Seal Team and and all
that stuff but yeah no but I love the
gram I'm big on the gram you know I'm
pretty responsive for the most part like
if people you know DM me or you can
always contact me through my website my
my trigger warning is that most of my my
gram photos you know are like frog man
Friday or like maybe spear fishing or
like you know there's there's it's
almost always it's almost all underwater
yeah yeah well that's that's uh uh now
we have uh the technology where you can
have a cameraman go with you ready to
take the photos totally God I needed I
need those guys in the teams yeah can
you imagine at uh at buds to have uh
have cameraman like I I do think a lot
about uh like the vlogging culture like
you see all these kids on on YouTube and
stuff like imagine when somebody starts
to go into the SEAL Teams like yeah I'll
come but uh my cameraman is the
don't gonna happen it's gonna happen to
do it it's a new Navy I I actually think
it's probably one of the best things the
uh Navy or Army could do right is like
uh go find one of these like influencer
people who has someone of a big audience
and say to them like hey you want to go
through Buds and again the overlap of
people who have an audience on the
internet and want to go through buds is
like probably not that big but you could
probably find one person and say hey
here's what we're gonna do is come out
and do it it's a recruiting video yeah I
mean maybe it's basically training and
not buds or whatever but like you could
figure something out I mean they did
this essentially right they had this
documentary about class 234 on Discovery
Channel and they've followed cameras
like all through and I've gone back and
and watched it some of those dudes
actually rolled into my class they got
hurt or whatever
um and I've and I've watched it and it
it's good like that's that's the best
part to bring this whole thing full
circle like there's no secret to buds
right there's no like all the secret
stuff happens after butts
you graduate buds you don't even know
that much about being a seal you do a
lot of push-up right but it's all right
there in plain sight you know you're
going to go to buds you're going to be
in the water you're going to lift some
logs right you're going to run around
with a boat on your head like no mystery
no steroids required right just be tough
and don't quit the the last thing I'll
say is uh we had a gold bar Lieutenant
show up uh in Iraq and uh E7 platoon
leader uh I just clear as day we'll
never forget this moment uh he said
something in the E7 system he goes hey
man in here you're the boss out there
I'm the boss yeah and I remember being
like there's levels of this [ __ ]
and I think it is it's like look there's
a training is obviously very important
but then there's the real world
application of this stuff and uh the
Navy SEAL some of the best in the world
are both well thanks man and thanks for
being such a advocate of the the
military veterans community that we that
we care so much about and being one of
these guys like like our buddy Jack Carr
who has has found his footing you know
in the in the civilian sector now it's
now it's our job to like lift our
military Brethren up with us absolutely
thank you so much for your time thanks